2021 was the year nfts went mainstream
[Music]
currency everyone and everything was all
about nfts
[Music]
so here's a look back at some of this
year's wildest nfts and the
mind-boggling amount of money they were
purchased for we can't kick this off
without the og of nfts beeple aka mike
winkelmann the 40 year old graphic
designer who lives in south carolina
he created every day's the first 5000
days a collection of all his digital
artworks in one major piece
it was the first time a major auction
house had offered an nft
and it sold for an insane amount of
money
69 million
346 thousand 250 dollars
i'm going to disney world
crypto punks are these algorithmically
generated little 24 by 24 pixel art
images kind of weird looking digital
characters they were created in 2017 and
were first offered free to anyone with
an ethereum wallet
fast forward to 2021 when sales of these
punks went for millions
these little guys paved the way for
board 8 yacht club which launched this
year
another wild sale former twitter founder
and ceo jack dorsey's first tweet sold
for
1630.58 ether roughly 2.9 million
dollars
dorsey converted the proceeds into
bitcoin and sent it to the charity give
directly the money going to some of the
poorest households in africa
and in a first for the music industry
rock band kings of leon was the first
band on a major label to release an
album as an nft
nft yourself wasn't a massive financial
success but it wasn't a failure either
and perhaps more importantly they showed
record labels the potential of nfts for
music distribution
a big trend this year was the sale of
meme nfts big winners this year doge
disaster girl scumbag steve charlie bit
my finger overly attached girlfriend
even bad luck brian sold for a whopping
36 thousand dollars but in true form he
couldn't keep all the profits to himself
to date the most expensive nft sale
happened in december 28
983 investors bought tiny tiny squares
of a large artwork with the option to
merge their pieces together to form part
of a larger hole
this sale effectively unseats jeff coons
and makes pack the most expensive living
artist in the world
with all the attention around nfts the
suit anonymous pack sale is also
significant for another reason some have
started to wonder if so many people
buying a single work of art isn't just a
security and could be regulated or if
the potentially ingenious decision to
actually give each investor a piece of
the art with the option to merge might
overcome those concerns
the final decision on this could impact
the way future art is sold for
generations to come
[Music]
you